les hommes font tout ce qu'ils peuvent
pour réaliser ce programme ambitieux
devenir une femme comme les autres les
valeurs dominantes dans la société puis
sont adoptées par les hommes sont toutes
des valeurs traditionnellement féminines
[Musique]
vous savez bien c'est la paix pas la
guerre le consensus pas l'autorité le la
précaution pas le risque etc et on voit
pour la politique c'est très intéressant
les femmes arrivées dans une profession
a au même moment le pouvoir désertent la
politique vous dit l'homme est un
prédateur sexuel un conquérant mais
c'est une incitation au viol ça non au
viol non pas du tout ah bah non en
prédateur sexuel saignant des mots qui
sont lourdement chargé mais tout à fait
vous avez tout à fait raison je continue
à penser qu'il y à de la violence dans
le rapport sexuel entre mes fans c'est
une violence civilisé en se levant il me
dit ah mais vous allez me remerciez
autrement et là il me faut à sa langue
dans ma bouche est il assez inattendu
des coûtants immonde diable quel
raccourci
jeu
je ne sais pas qui est cette dame
est c'est une des
logiciels qui vous accusez oui
harcèlement je veux pas je viens de
déposer contre vous je le précise des
merdes v6 et mais pourquoi avoir
seulement répondu que cela relevait de
votre vie privée parce que je n'ai
jamais agressé deux femmes on veut on
veut faire passer si vous voulez on veut
un continuum entre un comportement qui
est apparemment mis en cause est d'aider
une réflexion
moi je si vous voulez je ne considère
que je n'ai jamais agressé deux femmes
c'est tout maintenant c'est d'ailleurs
assez comment vous dire c'est grave de
faire cela parce que
ça
sert
comment vous dire ça
les vraies femmes agressées du coup ça
relativise les vrais agression voyez les
mots ne veulent plus rien dire c'est ça
que je veux dire bon maintenant je vais
pas me m'étaler sur sur cesser ces
pseudos dénonciation je voulais sur le
fond sur le fond il n'y a rien de
choquant dans ce que j'ai dit c'est
simplement j'analysais des comportements
j'analysais des imaginaires j'analysais
ddd sociologie une évolution jauge
opposaient des valeurs dites masculines
à des valeurs dites féminines et la
prévalence dans la société contemporaine
des valeurs dites féminines qui peuvent
s qui sont porté d'ailleurs par des
femmes mais aussi par des hommes et qui
sont les valeurs de paix de consensus
comme je les dis dans mes interventions
c'est un constat que font beaucoup de
gens j'ai vu j'ai pas eu le temps de le
lire malheureusement parce que je n'ai
plus le temps beaucoup lire pendant
cette campagne mais j'ai vu qu'emmanuel
todd université reconnue à gauche
reprend à peu près les mêmes analyses
dans son dernier livre voyez ça n'a rien
de particulièrement à l'époque c'était
plus original c'est tout avec beaucoup
de critiques aussi par mais bien sûr
bien sûr dernier en top 12 allée raison
et vous avez raison de réponse féministe
mais pas seulement
[Musique]